[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Jimin's "Like Crazy" playing ]
[ Music stops ]
-Yeah? Oh, oh, hi.
Oh, Jimin.
I -- what are you doing here?
-Can I come in?
-Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sure. Yeah, come on in.
[ Unsettling music plays ]
♪♪
Have a seat.
Uh, oh, let me clear
this for you.
This is...
Oh, sorry.
-You okay?
-Yeah, I'm great.
I'm happy you're
back on the show.
I mean, you have new music out.
Of course I didn't know that,
no one knew that.
I mean, it's out March 24th.
It's called "Face."
It's pretty awesome.
I heard the single.
But, you want a drink?
-Sure.
-Yeah, a drink would be good.
I'll get you a -- wow.
Uh, that's, uh, your face
is on the can,
but look, maybe I'll get you
a snack.
-Dr. Jimin?
-The snack will be good.
[ Air hissing ]
[ Balloons thudding ]
You know what? Let me email
my assistant
and I can get a snack,
we'll get something to eat.
Maybe we'll --
Whoa, this website's up here.
That shouldn't be there.
[ Laughs ]
Today is so funny.
Uh, okay, let me get this off.
Uh, let's --
That's your song. Well, that's
your song, of course.
You know that.
But that's --
Louder, it's louder now!
[ Volume rising ]
You know what? Maybe it's better
if I just see you out there.
I'll see you out on the floor.
-Good, good idea.
Thank you. Bye.
-See you.
-Thank you.
See you.
-[ Sighs ]
[ Music blaring ]
Jimmy is so cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]